un immense hall cours à la demande de la
famille
ce lundi 26 avril plus d'un millier de
personnes s'est rassemblée devant
l'hôtel de ville de rambouillet un
hommage est rendu à stéphanie mon ferme
et assassinée le 23 avril dernier au
commissariat
la fonctionnaire de police a ensuite été
inhumée au cimetière de saint léger en
yvelines en présence du président de la
république emmanuel macron 6 édiles en
colère les maires des communes de la
circonscription de police de plaisir ont
tenu une conférence de presse ils
protestent contre les annonces de
renforts fait par gérald darmanin et lui
demande de revoir sa copie un secteur
qui continue à fonctionner mais un
secteur en crise le bâtiment voit depuis
plusieurs semaines les matières
premières se raréfier entraînant une
augmentation des prix nettoyage et
restauration intégrale au château de
versailles la chapelle royale et le
cabinet d'angle du roi se sont refait
une beauté
trois ans de travaux pour la première un
nom pour le second la communauté urbaine
grand paris seine et oise va créer plus
de 126 km de pistes cyclables de
nouvelles places de stationnement et
aménager des rives un projet à 17
millions d'euros et des fruits et
légumes noté l'écho score nous informe
de l'impact environnemental d'un produit
alimentaire
ils sont classés de a à e
[Musique]